how do i get from where i am to where i
need to be
i didn't want to be rich i just didn't
want to be
poor want to be happy build a life not
just a business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you too you've got michael jordan level
genius at something so today let's live
your best believe life and learn the
five habits that are more
important than they seem enjoy
okay let's kick it off with habit number
one always be
exceptional with robert herjavec you
want to make a lot of money you want to
be successful
[Music]
how do i get from where i am to where i
need to be
i didn't want to be rich i just didn't
want to be
poor
[Music]
i started 10 years ago with a vision
and two employees and now we're 250
people we'll do 150 million this year
and every day when i get off the
elevator and i walk into my office
it it's this feeling of accomplishment
and satisfaction
knowing that i had this vision and a few
years later
it's real
[Music]
you know when we were when i was younger
my parents didn't speak any english
and like many immigrants since i was a
little kid i was eight years old when we
came to
north america and so i had to read the
contracts
you know my debt when my dad bought a
house
i had to read the mortgage and go
through the paperwork
and when i was around 18 or 17 i looked
at
being at that point we were you know
lower middle class
and i said how do i get from where i am
to where i need to be and so i started
calculating
how much money i would have to make in
order just to buy a house
and then i added the taxes into it and
all the other stuff
and i realized how difficult it was
going to be to accumulate
capital because that's the hardest thing
to do is to accumulate
capital it's one thing to get paid a lot
of money
but if you look at the tax system in
north america it's
really hard to amass capital
and i just decided that i didn't want to
be
where i was i didn't want to be middle
class or lower middle class or mediocre
i just wanted to be
great at something because i figured out
that the people that i
saw that were doing great things were
fundamentally
great at one thing the analogy i always
use is
peyton manning gets paid 10 million
dollars a year he doesn't get paid 10
million dollars a year
to tackle to kick the ball to play
defense
he gets paid 10 million dollars a year
to do one task
and do it really really well
nobody buys from you nobody makes you
wealthy because you're okay at something
the world does not reward mediocrity
nor does it reward average it only
rewards
exceptional so you got to find that
one thing that you're good at
and you got to become great at it
because if you focus what you're not
good at and try to become
good at it you're going to run into
somebody who is going to clean your
clock at it
habit number two guard your passion with
jeff bezos
many many kids and many grown-ups do
figure out
over time what their passions are and
sometimes we let our i don't think it's
that hard i think
what happens though sometimes is that we
let our
intellectual selves overrule those
passions
and so that's what needs to be guarded
against uh
kids are very good about knowing what
their passions are i love that
because i think i've seen you describe
this way that you've always maintained
that sense of wonder i think that's what
kids have
but we lose it somehow along the way yes
everybody it's a gift if you can keep
your child-like sense of wonder
and it helps with creativity it helps to
have fun
you know you laugh more and play more if
you keep that childlike sense of wonder
what's up everybody i want to talk about
the amazing book by evan carmichael
built to serve i want to read you guys a
section this is from
a part under the heading of your pain is
your strength this is the fundamental
mind shift that most people
never make but is required for success
the pain
that you went through that you're trying
to forget it's
your strength it's the way through it's
your answer
that pain is how you become the tree
you've experienced the pain
grow from it and are stronger now and
are able to help others who need
the support so there it is your pain
is the very thing that's going to get
you through it's kind of like what ryan
holiday says the obstacle is the way
all right guys check it out build a
serve by evan carmichael who could teach
a master class
on how to be a badass and be good to
people dude is rad check out his book
a lot of amazing stuff in there habit
number three start
serving others with oprah winfrey you
must
find a way to serve
martin luther king said that not
everybody can be famous but everybody
can be great because greatness is
determined
by service now we live in a world where
everybody wants to be famous
and where we admire people for just
being famous we think being known
brings us value the truth is all of that
will fade in time in three years you
won't be able to name the housewives
of atlanta
the real truth is that
service and significance
service and the significance that you
bring to your service
is that which is lasting so to be able
to
whatever your occupation or job
or talent or gift is
our honorees today getting doctor
degrees
to apparently opposite fields
hiv and aids and the spoken word
but what they have in common is service
using the spoken word in service to
community and the world
using your knowledge and information
about hiv and aids and medicine
in service to the world and if you look
at all the most successful people
in the world whether they know it or not
they have that paradigm of service
everybody's talking about mark
zuckerberg and ipo
service jay-z rapping
service through the word to people
through song for many years i was really
just happy to be on tv and people would
stop and say oh you're on tv
yeah i'm on tv i like being on tv
it's a nice job and it was about the
time that i
received my honorary doctorate from
spelman around 1993 so i don't know if
that had something to do with it i
thought of myself as dr winfrey
that i went back and i took a long look
at what it was i was doing on
on tv and made a decision
that i was no longer going to just be on
tv
but i was going to use tv
as a platform as a force for good
and not be used by tv and i will tell
you
my decision to make that significant
change in the way i operated
on television using television as a
service
changed my career exponentially
service through medicine service through
art using whatever it is
you produce your product as
a way of giving back to the world
when you shift the paradigm of whatever
it is you choose to do
to service and you bring significance to
that
success will i promise you
follow you service and significance
equals success habit number four manage
your time
better with dr miles monroe the key to
your future
is the successful management of time
and change you can't stop time
you can't stop change so all you can do
with them
is manage them and you become
what you are based on how you
manage both of them
i want to simplify life for you
tonight you are simply a product
of how you use your time
and how you manage the changes you've
been through so far
and what you become in 10 years from now
will be a result of how you manage the
time
and the changes so
when we talk about time let's talk about
time by itself for a minute time
is an amazing power
every day week month or
year is a gift
given to us by god
and that gift is given to us to fulfill
an assignment
and habit number five the last one
before a very special bonus clip
is use your pain with tom billy
as c.s lewis said hardships often
prepare ordinary people
for an extraordinary destiny people look
at their past
to decide who they are people look at
their past to decide who they can be
but the problem is oftentimes people
mistake
difficulties suffering pain
for being bad being less than being
broken and it erodes their sense of
self-esteem it erodes
their sense of self-worth but nothing
could be more opposite from the truth
because in reality
no matter what you've gone through no
matter how hard it was all of it
was shaping you into the person that you
can become the hardships the
difficulties the pain the suffering all
of that makes you
tougher it is literally in the
difficulties
that you begin to find just how much
you're capable of it's in
the suffering that you find out how
resilient you are it's in the pain
that you can rise up and get tough
and all of that is going to serve you as
you move forward but you have to know
how to frame it you have to know how to
think about it you have to know
that whatever you've been through that
all of it
is an opportunity to learn all of it is
an opportunity to
grow all of it is an opportunity to get
better but you have to
use it to shape yourself you have to
lean into it you have to know
that the pain and the suffering all of
it is serving you but if you're telling
yourself a story
that diminishes you if you're telling
yourself a story that bad things have
happened to me or i've done bad things
and that
makes me a bad person
then none of it is going to help you and
you're always going to move backwards
and it's going to be this stress and
this pressure that's pushing you
backwards instead
if you can put it behind you said it
pushes you forward it propels you to be
more
then no matter what's happened to you
you can become something truly
extraordinary
and as david livingstone said i'll go
anywhere
provided it'd be forward so even when
you're making mistakes
even when you're falling down if in that
you can see that it's
an opportunity it's a lesson it's
something that you've learned even when
you're running and you stumble and you
trip and you scrape yourself
all across the pavement you're still
moving forward
as long as you get back up dust yourself
off and keep going
it doesn't matter that you fail it
doesn't matter that you embarrass
yourself it doesn't matter that you made
a mistake or that you look stupid none
of that matters the only thing
that matters is how do you think about
it
do you let it be something that moves
you backwards
or do you recognize at least it was
momentum at least you were going at
least you tried at least you were
putting your energy into something
at least you were willing to take a risk
and that's where most people fail
they're never
willing to put themselves out there
because they don't see the momentum they
don't see the forward movement they
only see the failure
it really is that easy and i know that
you've heard this a thousand times and i
know that people are telling you
all the time the failure is a part of
the learning process
but so is the voice that says you're a
[ __ ] up
so is the voice that tells you that
you're unworthy
but it's up to you to decide to ignore
that voice it's up to you to prove that
voice wrong it's up to you to love
yourself
and yes i know that's easier said than
done
and yes i know each and every one of us
has to do things to be worthy
of loving ourselves we have to
take that leap of faith we have to be
willing to
look at our inadequacies we have to be
willing to get up and do
ourselves a service we have to be
willing to serve
ourselves and you do owe yourself that
and you do have to take action and you
do have to be proactive but if you do
that
you don't need extraordinary
accomplishments you just need to know
that you're trying you need to know that
when you fall you're going to get back
up you need to know that you'll keep
pushing forward you need to know that
you won't
give up now i've got a very special
bonus clip that i think you're going to
enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day
i want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week when you get motivated inspired
you have a 35 chance of following
through but when you get motivated
inspired and you create a plan of action
you have a over
90 chance of following through and when
you share with other people
it jumps to 95 chance your likelihood of
following through and so i want that to
be you
from this video we don't just watch
videos here believe nation we do
something we take action
so i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week leave it down in the comments below
because i want to celebrate you
successful people don't make excuses
it's so easy to make excuses most people
blame somebody else for why they're not
successful right it's the president's
fault
it's my country's fault it's the
education system's fault
it's my parents fault it's my friend's
fault it's
it's my bank's fault it's always
somebody else's fault
right it's easy and it's so it's always
easy to put the blame on somebody else
because it makes you feel good
because accepting responsibility sucks
saying that your business
is not more successful because of the
customers or the economy
or whatever it is it's so much easier
because it makes you feel good but it
keeps you where you are
and successful people the consistent
habit that they have
is they accept responsibility and don't
make excuses
your business is where you are because
of you
your life is where it's at because of
you your bank account is the size of
your bank account because of you
and when you accept that at the start it
sucks
right to say like this really sucks if
this really because of me
man i suck but it's also empowering
because you
have the ability to change it you don't
need to wait another x
number of years for a new president to
come in you don't need to wait an x
number of years for the economy to get
better you need to wait for anything
you just got to get on yourself and go
make a change
successful people don't make excuses
[Music]
if you want to know the five powerful
habits that will change your
life check out the video right there
next to me i think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there first of all
wake up at the same time every day my
life changed a couple years ago when i
discovered something called the progress
principle the one habit that you must
develop